okay so the topic of this video will be
a
main idea core concept comparison of
photosynthesis versus cellular
respiration so we'll be talking about
this picture as we progress let's get
started
so here is a picture of
of glucose the molecule gluca six
carbons 12 hydrogen six oxygens and this
is really the goal of photosynthesis is
to capture sunlight in order to produce
and create this molecule called glucose
and so who is performing photosynthesis
well it's autotrophs now we generally
think of plants but plants are not the
only autotrophs you also have algae
and kelp which is actually a type of
algae and even some bacteria the
cyanobacteria so there are lots of
organisms performing photosynthesis
aside from plants
and where does photosynthesis occur
generally speaking it occurs in this
organelle right here called a
chloroplast i say generally first of all
if we zoom on in we can see that there
are internal parts of a chloroplast here
but i say generally in a chloroplast
because i'm talking about plant cells
and algae cells eukaryotic cells but
there are some prokaryotes the
cyanobacteria that can do photosynthesis
and bacteria do not possess chloroplasts
but generally speaking photosynthesis
occurs within a chloro within the
chloroplast of cells
and so the core concept of
photosynthesis water sunlight and carbon
dioxide are going to be used to produce
glucose and some oxygen waste when we
look at the chemical formula of
photosynthesis or the equation of
photosynthesis the reactants would be
six molecules of water and six molecules
of carbon dioxide and energy in the form
of sunlight
will yield or will produce the the
products of photosynthesis would be a
molecule of glucose
c6h12o6 and six molecules of oxygen so
this is really the core concept right
here of what photosynthesis is
and so why is photosynthesis important
well
number one i mean oxygen is just
life-giving to a lot of organisms on
earth
but also the glucose that is produced as
a result of photosynthesis will be
transferred to your mitochondria
the mitochondria will use the glucose
and the oxygen for that matter
during the next topic we're going to
talk about cellular respiration in order
to make atp so photosynthesis makes
glucose that glucose goes to your
mitochondria and the mitochondria are
going to do cellular respiration in
order to make atp chemical energy
adenosine triphosphate which we'll talk
more about when we go into photo into
into cellular respiration right now
so if we shift focus for a moment and
talk about cellular respiration this is
a picture of the molecule called
adenosine triphosphate and this is
really the goal of cellular respiration
to create this molecule this energy
molecule called
abbreviated atp adenosine triphosphate
well who who is able to perform cellular
respiration
autotrophs and heterotrophs so it's not
just animals that perform cellular
respiration but also protista
and fungus and even plants so animals
perform cellular respiration
plants perform photosynthesis as well as
cellular respiration
so where does cellular respiration occur
it occurs within the mitochondria plants
have chloroplasts but they also have
mitochondria
animal cells just have the mitochondria
animals lack chloroplasts so animals
will perform cellular respiration only
and the core concept of cellular
respiration
is the glucose and oxygen from
photosynthesis are going to be used to
create a lot of atp
and we look at the equation the
reactants
or the inputs of cellular respiration
you get a molecule of glucose
and six molecules of oxygen
will yield
the products
six molecules of water
six molecules of carbon dioxide and
energy in the form of atp under certain
conditions maybe around 36 to 38
molecules of atp
now if we compare these reactions here
if we compare the formulas of
photosynthesis versus cellular
respiration i hope you realize i hope
you notice these are what we kind of
call mirror images of one another the
reactants of photosynthesis are the
products of cellular respiration
the products of photosynthesis are the
reactants of cellular respiration so you
can see how hopefully nicely how these
two processes
are are interwoven
to be reliant reliant upon each other
and so why is cellular respiration so
important
well atp adenosine triphosphate it is
the fuel that your cells use all cells
need energy and that energy comes in the
form of atp
atp provides the energy for cells to do
their work in order for cells to survive
and carry on the processes of life they
need to make atp
and so what we see here in this
animation
the chloroplast through photosynthesis
produces glucose and oxygen that glucose
and oxygen go to the mitochondria the
mitochondria will take the glucose and
oxygen and create atp
that atp is the energy
for cells to do the work they need to do
to survive
notice notice what comes out of the
mitochondria waste comes out
water waste and carbon dioxide waste
which can be used by the chloroplast to
do photosynthesis so i hope you see how
these two processes are connected
to one another
okay as i wrap this up if we look at the
picture on top that's a diagram of a
plant cell and here is a chloroplast and
here is a mitochondria so imagine
sunlight enters the plant cell
and is absorbed by the chloroplast
photosynthesis occurs and g for glucose
g for glucose is released look where the
glucose goes
into the mitochondria
the mitochondria will absorb this
and then create atp and that atp like it
says on the right hand side of the
screen is energy used by the cells
that atp will provide the power that
cells need to do their work plant cells
have work to perform and the atp is the
energy they need to do it
look at the picture on the bottom it's
an animal cell well there's no
chloroplast but there are still
mitochondria here's mitochondria
so animal cells need atp but they don't
make glucose how do animal cells get
glucose well we get glucose from the
outside
by consuming food the food that we eat
has glucose in it the glucose is
digested and eventually makes its way
into our cells where it's absorbed into
the mitochondria the mitochondria of our
animal cells can then create atp and
like the notes say atp is the energy
used by cells it provides the power that
cells need to do their work so i hope
this nice little connection here between
photosynthesis and cellular respiration
has been helpful thanks for watching